[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
oh was there a delay yeah
oh [ __ ] okay wait wait
ready count to three right starting now
one
one two three we have a delay
we got a delay there's just nothing we
could do about it right
i mean i'm plugged into the router here
wait so do you hear me right now so you
so okay
i'm hearing you right as you're saying
it yeah right now i'm hearing you right
here you hear me
right yeah hear you maybe clap
one of you clapping the other one pimp
you count to three
okay you ready we'll clap one two
three delay
wait maybe we hear pimp in real time
hello no was delayed i heard him quicker
you did okay you are
[Music]
my
i'm gonna say a sentence and i'm gonna
say tell me exactly when you hear me
and you say now when i say the word um
backstreet say okay just heard it okay
ready
backstreet just heard it i'm ahead of
you
got it okay but you you say back street
back street just heard it
delayed yeah sorry guys there's nothing
we could do
okay so what if that's just the intro
what if we just that all was the intro
one two three you
are my
[Music]
since the first time i think this is the
first time in my 36 years of life
that i've been more than two months
apart from you
yeah this is crazy this is crazy and now
we're on a delay
because yeah now and and as if it wasn't
bad enough
now the internet delays us babe
i miss everything i miss everything from
the smell of your beard
to to to this to the to the feel of your
hair
to to you know i just gentle touch
the other day i was sitting down and i
had my pillow like this
and i said i just want somebody to push
the corners in
yeah i i i
i mean you're out there you're chrissy
l.a
you're yes chrissy christie truetv chris
clay chrissy chaos chrissy patreons out
there
yes percy chrissy social media
influencer out there
chris chrissy down six pounds chrissy
down six pounds
sally take that six raise your six up
no no no no no hold on wait a second
wait a second wait a second you're not
up on weight
you think you're up on weight today
starts my day
where you're gonna see a transformation
from from me
today but now it's my day now the fans
want to know you're going to lose
because listen i've known sal a long
time and
he can lose weight and stick to a diet
he's got the mental
um the mental strength of it's
unprecedented
but what the fans want to know is you
will lose i know you will lose the
weight we all know you're going to lose
30 plus pounds
will you shave the beard to to give
yourself
to assist with the weight loss or are
you going to keep it okay
i'm getting sick and tired of the hair
and beard it's the summer months now
i'm already contemplating shaving it
down about three quarters of the way
on both right that being said i never
really
was at like a real low weight because my
weight fluctuates a lot
i was never at a real low weight with
long hair so
there was a part of me that was like
should i should i get down like you know
and then and keep the long hair in the
long beard but i think i'm just
so i'm just so tired of it i think i'm
just going to get cleaned up
here's what i'll say about the beard and
the hair for you
it served its purpose i would say it
served its purpose
and now because here's what's happening
to me i've been out i've been out in l.a
for a little while multiple times now
this is two or three times at it's only
happened in starbucks i don't know why i
think people in starbucks just feel like
you know that drinking coffee in a good
mood they come say hello to what
happened in the starbucks on ventura in
studio city
it happened in the starbucks in burbank
and then it happened at starbucks in
orange county
people came up to me they said hey babe
they introduced themselves by saying hey
babe
told me they enjoyed the show which i
appreciate then followed up with
when is sal shaven i've been asked that
question
it's affecting my life now
[Laughter]
oh man you know what i'll do oh no
really
i don't shave you never really grow
what's the most growth you've ever had
on that face
it doesn't it's not that i haven't
wanted to because if i had the
capability to to to have a beard like
you i would have done it
i can't grow the hair past a certain
point it comes in very patchy
yeah and it doesn't look at what your
beard would be my beard is not a good
beard at all
i couldn't even come close to that i
couldn't even i couldn't even come right
now
give yourself a chance you can't be hard
on yourself like this you got to get did
you ever listen to me
i never thought i would either until i
just said
the hell with it i'm gonna let it go and
then i realized oh that was a mistake
but my point is is that you never know
unless you let it go
i've never seen you with growth much
past what you have right now
no i i haven't i i just because because
genuinely my body doesn't
let my face grow at all it just will not
it will not grow
it will not do anything um what about
this as an idea as a transition for you
what if we shave the beard but we leave
the mustache for you
what do you think of that okay a couple
things one i don't like that your body
is
is really controlling your face and
you're having a war like it's almost
like a civil war
between your body and your face yeah uh
i think you need to
get to a place where they both agree
with each other i would love to see you
with like 90-day growth because you you
only rock a george michael faith
is the most you'll do right it's like
it's always like three
it's like a 3 p.m shadow that's all i
get as
i grow to this length pretty quickly and
then we have a full stall
it just stalls it doesn't go any longer
how about this you ready for this cell
how about this once you shave yours
i'll start growing mine that's a lot of
fun
that's a lot of fun we'll do we'll do a
yo-yo we'll do a flip-flop
i like it so here's what i was i always
intended full-on when i shaved the beard
all the way down or like like your
length to leave and not only leave but
even grow in the mustache a little bit i
want to see myself
as a mustachioed man i have yet to see
it in my life i've never had just a
stash
i used to think it was so antiquated it
was so 70s it was so out of style
and i don't know if it's my age or
fashion being cyclical or what it is
but now i start to like i go in the
mirror and i go like this
and i like say lines like regular for my
life like can i get a half pound i was a
damn shredded then
whatever and i look i look at what i
would look like if i just had a stash
and i like it it looks good with your
sushi i mean listen
it is zoom here's the thing here listen
not only are we on zoom but
i'm looking at you at the upward angle
which is notorious the worst angle for
the human face
and you look good with just a beard with
a full man chew
right i think so i personally think so
what i was going to suggest was that i
shave it
on the pod but i know i know but
here's the thing i don't really because
this is unruly and because i really
don't know how to
you know live on my own or anything my
guy who cuts my hair always does my
beard
i can't touch his what he does i go in
there i go
make it look like i want to look natural
before a little here and he goes out no
problem and he just throws me back puts
a hot towel on my face
and like a half hour later he's going in
this guy's going in
he has different sized scissors i hear
him snipping singular hairs at a time
the guy is sculpting like edward
scissorhands in the front yard
and i can't i can't do it like him so i
always end up
messing up i get the buzzer and i get
like real brazen like i think i know
what i'm doing
i get frustrated and i and i gotta and
then i mess it up here and i gotta
overcompensate
so i don't know if doing it on the
podcast is the best move
but it is for the fans it is for the
listeners for sure what if we have first
of all it's another great patreon idea
when we make the patreon it's another
great idea
to do that as soon as you come home from
la the patreon is starting we got to
start the patreon
it's starting start it's 100 gonna start
there's no choices now
there's no choices now um no we'll get
your barber
we'll get your barber on the podcast to
do that that'll be no problem
and it'll be good but before we say
anything else sal
before we say anything else again i
haven't seen you in a while i haven't
spoken to you i just want to say
and obviously i know that you'll second
me on this i just want to give a quick
congratulations out to the tampa bay
bucks for winning the super bowl and
shout out to the
chiefs they gave it a very good run tom
brady
and the bucks i'm brady you can't
undersell what tom brady did at 43.
oldest guy in the nfl comes in wins his
or was it his seventh ring or something
like that
yeah so who knows something clever i
said
yeah 70th ring yeah and and again crazy
he went to the box and then that year
just so happens
super bowl in tampa but you gotta i
agree you gotta give it up for the
chiefs
god patrick holmes and the chiefs are
doing big things yeah patrick mahomes
shout out and you know it's uh yeah i
just saw him
uh uh he just went to a comedy show in
dallas he went to andrew santino's
comedy show in dallas just want to say a
quick shout out thank you to andrew
santino
for filling in for filling in the shoes
to fill in for the shoot
to fill the shoes of sal volcano is not
an easy it's not easy it's not easy to
do what he did
and andrew but he did so well that a lot
of the fans just thought that sal died
his
hair and beard that's how well andrew
did
andrew is if there's anyone to sit in
for me it's definitely we made the right
choice with andrew he just fits right in
if there was like another member of our
team like if we were ever like
accepting applications he'd be first on
the list he'd be first we'd cut deroza
out right away and we'd move in santina
look at this guy look at that look at
joey
taste buds great by the way our hey babe
sign came in
yes and it is currently at pimp's place
and as soon as you get home next week
we're putting it right up we're going to
put it right up me and pip will do it
and
we'll have it we'll have a good time
what's the guy's name do you remember
his name
ted you're the ted uh ted mosaic ted
mosaics go follow him on instagram
um yeah baby i i mispronounced his name
last time someone told me and i don't
wanna do it again
but i think it's m-u-n-z and yeah that's
his real name ted moons yeah
10 moons okay there you go god bless you
god bless him god bless
god bless and we also have a new fan
painting that will go up in the studio
we have a new fan painting pimp is also
saying we'll unveil that
okay i've been like you you i feel like
you have like a
like a real world house going on over
there from the clips i've seen
the freeway runs right through that that
house that you you rented this beautiful
place
you got a pool you got a big circular
staircase you got people coming in and
out of there
like it's old hollywood yeah it's it
though true
chaz palminteri is coming to stay with
us today for the next
seven days chad's playing terry and his
entire family will be staying in the
house
with me swear to god he him and his
entire family are coming
so it's gonna get crazy how many
i think he's a party of four a party of
four it's a party of four
how many bathrooms in that place we got
we got three bathrooms okay so
and one of them doesn't work so okay so
you got you got your bathroom he has his
bathroom
pretty much listen it's going to get
dicey i mean it's going to get the icy
we're coming down to the wire here but
what am i what was it supposed to do say
no to transparent here you can't say no
no you can't say no to transvoluntary
that would end up bad for you
here's what i think though i would love
to see chas palmitary's bathroom routine
you know like just like how he gets
ready because he's such a sharp dressed
man
he's an old school guy i'm sure he has a
nice he does i'm sure he's just like an
open
those i'm sure he shaves himself with
like a like like a like an exposed razor
he probably puts on a lot of aftershave
alana and you know what you know what
i'm sure he's i'm sure he's doing okay
with his products but if he wants to
come up
if he wants to be a step above and
really get going all he needs to do is
go to manscape.com
promo code hey babe and his life will
really be
in control but that's another day i'll
talk to you about it when you get
another day but i think you should talk
to i i would love it if you report it
back to me
on chas palmitary's balls and
and and if he thinks they're up to par
or does he think he could be a a that's
a
netscape manscaped
a manscape model man or netscape he
probably still uses
well listen how about this if you know
because obviously homeless pimp is
staying with us and obviously sal you
and i know homeless but better than
anybody
i wouldn't put a pass homeless if he's
already pre-wired the bathrooms with
some of his cameras
that we won't in fact have live action
shots
of chas palm and terry's grooming
schedule that you could probably see
only on our patreon when we release it
which is going to be soon and i don't i
don't disagree with you at all pimp is a
content machine and also by the way
though i'm just just as i'm hearing you
say this
maybe right now you got to just call him
pimp because not only does he have a
home but
it's it's on the grand scale there not
only i mean homeless pimp went to
you know yeah now he's pimpy's got a
better home than both of us i mean
yeah oh how about this you ready for
this sal please
you ready you ready for what what the
homeless pimp's actual name should be
now
is florence nightingale jesus
lord and savior he say you ready for
about
this is 100 true and i'm about to tell
you oh
homeless pimp saved chas palm and
terry's life
last week did you hear about this scale
of 1 to 10 that's a 10
out of 10 true like really saved his
life
chaz palminteri was choking on a chicken
parm hero
at the dining room table only pimp and
chas were there
chas starts tapping on pimp's shoulder
saying motioning
i can't breathe lips turning blue pimp
springs up into action in his corduroy
pants
and his uv light sun goes legs the one
with the very wide
leg the wide-legged pants yeah gets his
gets his uh fingers interlocked in a
fist position
finds chas palmitari's navel starts
pushing in
expels the chicken parm sandwich into
the floor chest throws up in the sink
saved his life five minutes after this
whole thing went down chaz interviewed
billy joel didn't mention a word
he interviewed billy joel billy joel on
zoom didn't mention a word about what it
just ensued moments before
wow by the way finding chad commentaries
naval sounds out the name of a great
docu-series
i mean are we are we not going to have
merch that say chaz palmitary's name
are we doing that or what i would love
to and by the way
you can look at footage of pimp giving
chas palmerton the heimlich
finding his navel and then the chicken
shooting out only on the patreon
which is because there's no way cameras
weren't rolling am i right
pimp that's the first thing pimp did
he's actually subtitling the clip now
wait how does pimp because i just had
this conversation forever in my life
i wanted to know cpr and the heimlich
because well i just don't want the day
to come where i
should have known it and then someone
pays the price in a bed yeah
so pimp actually that i never asked you
this what what like what did you do
what was running through your head um i
i didn't know anything i just kind of
guessed
and actually after the fact what yeah i
just knew like people get broken ribs so
i just went at the ribs
and then afterwards chaz actually said
my form was so bad he's gonna pay to get
me lessons
[Laughter]
i love it he's telling you about your
form but he saved his life
yeah fully saved his life so oh my god
wait did chaz acknowledge that he
now owes you his life and if he did what
what comes along
uh what price is that like you gotta do
you have him now
does he does he owe you a debt of
gratitude now that like really
the world is your oyster well can we
decide what chaz owes you
i mean what would you guys want someone
to oh
i gotta be honest with you because i
spoke to chaz this morning before he got
on the flight he said and he texted me
he said hey
when i land first thing i'm going to do
is take all you guys out to dinner
because you know pimp saved my life last
week i said you got to do better than
that babe
we're going to get a dinner that doesn't
go good for you chaz the last time we
had a dinner
we almost died yeah really i mean by the
way dinner is very
nothing against chess but at dinner
dinners come and go you do dinners as
a gesture well you saved his life you
say i mean
why you got to do something left you
know like right now i'm in the state of
california
you know my daughter's birthday's in two
days nobody can get into disney world to
disneyland without
legal california id chaz why don't you
make that happen for us why don't you
make disney happen for us paul strings
you know you your life was saved what
are you going to do with it now
yeah you got to pay it forward right now
to to your daughter
to disney he walks in he closes the gate
throws the
switch up the lock and says now you
can't leave that's what he's got
you put a gun you put a gun to mickey
mouse's head and you make
you make the fricking gates go up how
sick is chas
palm and carry of people quoting bronx
tale to him
how sick is he of it or is he like you
know what it's it's my
it's my it's my piece there is a stance
say it to me all day and night
it is iconic and what you're telling you
you you quoting it to me tells me
tell it tells me it's iconic or is he
just like i get it
i made bronx tale leave me the phone
see i think chaz is one of the guys that
leans into it for example i had him do a
video
for my daughter's you know uh school
like fundraising day like you know
catholic school
and i had chaz do with me and chaz did a
video
saying you know you know kind words
about the school and getting through the
pandemic and then at the end the last
minutes chad said remember kids
nobody cares
it gets both ways but like so this these
days where i feel like that is the best
advice i've ever heard
and then there's days that i feel like
that is bleak advice
but today i i feel like that's let me
tell you something what happened to me
recently not to just i know we'd adhd in
this podcast
and then by the way and then i got a
story about david blaine go ahead go oh
god this is great okay yeah i'm getting
wallpaper put in right
it's been like a months-long process
first i had to pick the wallpaper
then they had to come measure for it and
it's going on a really weird set of
walls that have all different
measurements
so it was a custom order it took eight
weeks longer than it should have
and then it got here and then i had to
schedule the guy that they recommended
he came
he took two sets of measurements all
this stuff right so he's supposed to be
here on thursday
now right this is a months-long process
i got like a hundred rings of goddamn
wallpaper downstairs in a tube and when
he came the first time
he measured everything and he says
here's my rate you order the paper
that's independent of me
my rate it's a one-day job he says i
could do the three panels that you need
and i lost because i was going to
wallpaper another spot in the house he
goes
and i wallpaper another spot in the
house no problem
because it's all this it'll all take me
all one day so i'll charge you for a day
rate
850 bucks done deal this is what he
tells me months ago i'm like
terrific like come here do it okay he's
supposed to be here so last week
i text him i got the wallpaper can you
come this week he says i'm gonna need
two weeks i'm not i'm busy i said hey
whenever you can come he says how about
next thursday
i said no problem 10 a.m no problem i
wait to 10 days
it's this thursday i text him today i
say hey
thursday at 10 am we're still on he goes
yes 8 50 for the first job
200 bucks for the second job so i said
oh
i said do you remember like the
conversation we had
you just mentioned that you could throw
in the second panel because it's all one
job it's a small wall
so you were just gonna say like you said
850 for the whole day
what do you think his next text that
that's by the way
that's what he said i said thursday 10
a.m we're good
he says yeah 8 50 for the first job 200
for the other job
i say okay but didn't you mention that
they were all one job and you could do
them all in one day and you'll throw in
the second one
for the same fee what do you that's what
i said
what do you think his next text was back
to me
i mean i'll tell you what
it was four words
god bless the usa what did he say yes
he said find another paper hanger
what this
this mother he says that
he went from zero to a million i i just
and i wrote him back i go
what do you i go wait i said why would
you respond to me in this fashion
i said everything's been courteous and
polite for the last few months
i said i'm not even objecting i just was
bringing up what you told
me i said if there was a
miscommunication all you do just simply
please tell me i said
i don't need another wallpaper hanger
you can come i said but
again that is definitely what you told
me i'm just that's all i'm
saying it's been six hours hasn't texted
me back
this so the one of a [ __ ] the wallpaper
hanger
left sal volcano on red that's what
happened he left you on red
and nobody cares according to chad's
former territory that rings nobody cares
and i want chaz maybe would chas have a
word with him for me is what i want to
know
oh no no no no we could tell you no sal
i could tell you things off
air that jazz chaz has offered to have
words
with a couple of people in my life that
me and
homeless pimp are dumbfounded that we
even got this call from chaz
but it's off air content or maybe
patreon
but certainly not oh okay here's what we
do
i'm gonna show chazz the tax chain i'm
gonna let him
absorb the emotional feeling i had
because it's nice to see it firsthand
i let him get nice and fired up if he
agrees to do this we will call this man
on patreon we'll call him on
speakerphone
chat we'll have a few words with him no
no yeah no no
you will get this guy this is like no
joke this is like
12 weeks in the making he's supposed to
come thursday
by the way i didn't even care i even
threw it i wrote and i followed up that
text with
i could care less about the extra money
man i'm just telling you what you told
me out of principle yeah
yeah doesn't tell them respond leave me
tell them hey listen i got
i got a hundred yards of wallpaper
leaning on say guy and you tell him say
buddy
money's not different to me i've been on
true tv nine years i make thousands of
dollars
so thousands so what's a little
i don't care and also i can afford i can
afford to pay for two of these wallpaper
jobs
two of them no problem by the way could
call it i've never heard of the
profession i guess they call themselves
wallpaper hangers
i wouldn't think i never he said that's
the first time i heard it he didn't say
wallpaper
he said find another paper hanger find
another paper
and so listen if you guys want to be
correct and you want to respect
have a respect for everybody inclusive
community you call
these people paper hangers that's what
they want to be called
find another paper hanger real quick
real quick fun fact
bubble wrap has been around for more
than 50 years in 1957
american engineers alfred fielding and
mark chaviness
set out to create textured wallpaper
after sealing together two shower
curtains with air bubbles trapped inside
the pair discovered their 3d wall
covering wasn't as popular as they hoped
but in the meantime they invented bubble
wrap so just an fyi
wow i love bubble wrap i almost think if
you don't like the popping sounds of
bubble wrap
you and i probably can't and won't be
friends you're predisposed to not
enjoying life in anything yeah
it's like come on don't be a criminal
stepping on bubble wrap i mean it's the
most fun thing to do
you step i twist you twist wow see i
still step on it i actually every time i
get bubble wrap
i mean i take my shoes and socks off and
i crack them all with my toes
that's right that's what i like to do
that's nice that's the better that's
better than me
that's better i'm going to start doing
that you ever do this job you ever get
an empty tic tac
uh little empty tic tac container and
you and you do this trick to your friend
you put it in the palm of your hand
right and you go oh i gotta i gotta i
gotta crack my neck and you go like this
and you crush the tic tac container and
it goes
crack and then they flip out no you've
never heard of that never done that i'm
looking at homeless pimp's face i could
see it he's never done that
so do yourself a favor when this podcast
stands go down to the bodega the corner
bodega in la over there
buy yourself some buy like a little like
three tick tacks at least four
two each right and then do it do it to
someone and i'm telling you right now
it is it pays off so much more than what
you paid for the tic tacs
it looks like you are cracking your
entire neck
i i mean i've seen so many people do it
so i know it's
it's not just me but i guess it never
made its way to you so you know what i'm
about to tell you right now which
pimp and i have spoke about this and you
kind of just hit you kind of just
daggered in the heart
no bodegas in l.a yeah i know i was
being sarcastic
i know you did that to hurt me what do
they have
they don't even have delis they got
nothing no no no they got enough time
outside of the supermarket is there a
corner store you're getting a great
sandwich from with a slicer
we haven't we haven't found one of them
now i'm sure people watching the show
say oh we're in the wrong places
fine maybe that's true my only counter
argument is
in new york city you will you would have
even if you're not in the right place
you'll find the sandwich place
you'll find the pizza place you'll find
it in new york l.a
that's what i think i don't like about
this city as compared to new york is la
you got to go find stuff
new york the stuff finds you boom i mean
that's a
really nice you should pitch that to the
borough of uh
uh tourism yeah yeah because because now
all the signs just say forget about it
but what if we may i'm going to make the
signs new york finds you
new york finds you board of tourism
would eat that up that's really good
buddy that's snappy that's catchy here
we go new york
so david blaine you can throw a rock
anywhere
you throw a rock and you hit either a
pizzeria a bagel store or a sandwich
spot in new york
oh 100 100 but we're not condoning
throwing rocks you shouldn't throw rocks
no let me ask you a question what just
using that like throwing a rock in la
what are you hitting what's the most
common thing you see
in la over and over that you would say
that that's the equivalent of the new
york
pizzeria bodega type of thing is it like
it's a coffee shop coffee shop i mean
there is no yeah but you got that in new
york too though
yeah but this i would say la you know at
least in the
part i'm in you'll hit you'll hit a
coffee shop you'll hit a person walking
their dog
or any and you also will hit a cvs
i would say i've seen more cvs's more
people walking their dogs
and more coffee shops than i've seen
back in new york what does cvs stand for
pimp wow let's let me take it down the
screen
um centralized
vehicle store you ready for what it is
care
care service
[Music]
velociraptor are you ready sally you
ready for what it is
yeah am i going to tell by all of you
what is it consumer value store
i gotta say it makes sense
it kind of makes sense it's a letdown
it's a letdown
what does the aap stand for and page i
believe
and paige i thought it was ann
and paige the aunt can you look that up
yeah he's looking it up what does that
no you ready for what it stands for sal
yeah the great atlantic and pacific tea
company
oh i might have known that so let me ask
you do you have trouble getting an
erection or maintaining an erection
right this moment you you see telling me
right now you you really having a tough
time getting an erection
yeah i've been trying for i didn't tell
you but i've been trying
and right not happening right now you
know what it's i didn't want to say it
but i noticed it because even doing the
episode on zoom i said nine times out of
ten when i do a zoom
with sal his erection takes up some of
the screen but this time
it hadn't so i said what's going on yeah
yeah
is there anything that you could offer
me advice or anything i could do
normally there wouldn't be but actually
today i can
all you have to do is go to bluechew.com
okay blue blue chew if you don't know
what it is it's a unique online service
um it's got the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis
but it's chewable form because i know
you can't swallow pills
so this is the chewable form for the
fraction of the cost and i'm gonna give
you a major discount my friend
go to bluechew.com put in the promo code
hey babe and guess what if you put in
that promo code hey babe
at checkout you're gonna only pay the
five dollar shipping and then you're
gonna get your first
month free so one month free
bluetooth.com promo code hey babe
all you got to do is pay the five dollar
shipping i can loan you the five dollars
if you need it
i will tell you right this second i
don't even know if i'm gonna do that
anymore because just
hearing that deal made me fully erect
what are those pills in your hand
oh babe come on what do you know about
this
sunday scaries now i'm easy
i'm easy like sunday scary's
what do they do wait wait hold on hold
on wait a second wait a second wait a
second
wait a minute wait you just took the cbd
gummy
the sunday scares the ones that are the
best f and cbd products
the ones that turn the wtfs into lols
though absolutely the remedy that makes
life not so scary gummies for chilling
with cbd
not even a vegan af one good you know me
i'm very high strung i'm like a very
old old old jewish woman that's how i am
well look these sunday scaries they
guess what they added b12 and d3 i play
d3 basketball
yeah so you know all about it then
that's what you know right
look at me you turn me from an old
person
to a chill a chill young a young fella
now listen
here's the thing sal is i would get them
you know i would get them you know i
love the sunday scares you know i love
you know i'm vegan as f af you know that
i love that's my favorite cbd company
the problem is
is i don't have any more money so i
can't afford them
so there's nothing i can do right what
are you a lunatic don't get shook in
2021 but i'll get 25
off at sundayscaries.com by using our
promo code
25 off at sunday scaries with the promo
code heybig that's all you got to do
i mean cbd is exploding right now it's a
big business and
i'm telling you this one is awesome
they're just fun the flavors are good
they got this unicorn jerky i love they
got it in cbd oil
and it's just really relaxing this one
has b12 and d3 in it
and it's a vegan formula so i mean it's
really a no-brainer
you just go online to sundayscaries.com
you put in the promo code hey babe you
get 25
off you can afford it anyone can afford
it
as long as you you know at least work
one day a week or something i'm sure you
can
i don't want to open so you know what
now
you just made me happy with that 25 off
discount i can't afford the sunday
scares i'll do exactly what you told me
to do
and then this way i'll forget about
becky's showboat instagram account which
is really keeping me up at night
that's what you gotta do there it is
i don't know how many grams i'm supposed
to take but i really want to relax
tonight so
there you go the sunday scaries hey babe
yeah that's a better that's a better
thing than customer value center
service customer cv now
i'm kind of feeling like cvs doesn't
really care about me
like it's cvs cbs used to be called
savon do you remember that
remember save on drugs no i think cvs
used to be called
unless it was just save on because back
in the day the big powerhouses
the drugstores were like save on and you
remember genovese
of course remember eckerd yeah eckerd
yeah yeah
i don't know if these are local new york
things they are local new york things
okay yeah yeah because remember there
was another there's a big one local in
new york called dwayne reed dwayne reed
and that that's just the two streets
it's on dwayne and reed and then it
would turn into a chain
yeah yeah dwayne reed yeah like a good
green reed i'm not bad
yeah i hope that the that the you know
there's a lot
there's an uh you know i like a mom and
pop store
i i don't want this whole world to just
be
amazons and targets and walmart's if
they'd like to sponsor the show we're
listening
but i don't i don't want it to just be
that you know what i mean
yeah i i love a neighborhood mom and pop
especially
pharmacy like i grew up i grew up going
to one
police uh in staten island police
drugstore pharmacy and that's still
there
uh but it's like and it's like old
school but it's like yeah there's
there's
hardly any neighborhood drug stores like
that anymore
because because sometimes the two times
in my life that i've been given the
wrong medication
both times it's been at a big store like
a cvs not a mom and pop stop
pop store yeah yeah and i don't like
i don't like going into cvs for
medication
you don't you know no i don't even get
from a cvs
what's that what do you get then you're
going what
items are you comfortable getting from a
cvs
for sure for sure i pick up my
in-between items uh
in between supermarket stops so maybe
i'll get some milk some paper towels
uh i'm not above a deodorant in a cvs
god bless them
uh maybe a shampoo uh
snacks some chips some pretzels maybe
paper plates napkins maybe some beans
not chips and pretzels after today
though that's the old cell
no this is the old sal now that's it i'm
cutting out
i'm cutting out fried foods and i'm
cutting out sweets
i'm starting my day every day with a
green juice you know what you know
what's really good thing about human
beings or at least
you know guys like us and hopefully it
doesn't happen to you because it's one
thing
when we gain and lose weight the pants
don't fit
the shirts don't fit but do you imagine
could you imagine
if your feet got fatter and skinnier and
all of a sudden your sneakers fit or
didn't fit based off you gaining weight
that would be a whole different ball
game for sneakers thank god your feet
stay relatively the same size throughout
i couldn't agree more
to something very finalized about a shoe
purchase
for some reason like you know we're like
i'll wear my my bigger pants my
small bell i got to get new pants but if
your feet got fat it changed shoe sizes
the whole industry would be on its head
did you imagine you buy 300
pair of jordans because because you were
size 11 but now you went in a binge
you're a size 15 you can't fit your fat
foot in there anymore
i actually used to do a bit because you
know what else isn't affected by weight
gain
the penis no now a lot of women
if they gain weight their breasts gain
weight but
it was insane if it was the same for the
penis
you would see 600 pound men walking all
across the land 100
now here's a question here's a double
down question but
i understand the breasts get bigger do
the vaginas get
fatter or skinnier with women gaining
weight that i don't know
i don't have firsthand knowledge i don't
know right i don't i haven't really
i haven't really noticed and and it's a
good question
yeah listen it's like just just so just
a just a bigger all-around
area and sal and i are going around new
york city when i get back when you ask
women questions who have recently gained
weight
has their vagina gained weight and we
can do that only on the patreon so if
you guys want to sign up you'll see
that that's going to be strictly patreon
it's interesting yeah
you know because because i'm at a point
now
where i've been i'm out of because you
know as we you know
it's still the same i've still been
logging food into my fitness pal but
what's happened now to me sal
is now i used to be very anal
about oh i'm not going to go over my
allotted calories which is 2200 cows
but now i kind of haven't been seeing
results for the last month and i'm
starting to take it out
a little bit on my fitness pal so now
for example yesterday
at the end of the night i had about
200 calories to spare which the old me
would have said
okay have a little fruit have something
200 cows or less
but i said ah what's the difference
anyway and i ordered pizza hut
so i some no i don't i can't figure
you you're putting a system on trial i'm
putting the system on trial
that's right yes so so my thing now
is you know i don't know if if my
brain has a thing where it always needs
to have some type of conflict or
something to get through because
i was getting to my goals and now that
i'm within striking distance of them i'm
saying no
no let's go back so i don't know if my
brain wants to keep me
fat i don't know what's happening
i think that i think plateauing in terms
of like diet and exercise is normal and
i think you got to do something to shake
it up
i think that i mean you would know
better than i you're much more in this
world than i am but what i'm saying is
i think having the pizza hut you said
pizza hut
pizza hot stuffed crust oh wow delivery
nobody beats the hut wow i don't know if
we have that over here maybe that's the
one thing la has over us
no sal you have pizza huts and you have
cinnabon places we've went over this
i didn't know about it
your whole body implodes on the inside
they're like what the hell is going on
and maybe you you whip them back into
shape i think you need to carb load
interesting okay so what would you
suggest for me to shake it up
i think you do like
half a week where you act
like you don't even understand anything
about food you just discovered it
yeah you know what is calories what is
saturated fat what is cholesterol what
is sodium
you don't know just go like like
just like nobody's like nobody's even
looking at you and you just eat
and then and then just like you've got
you're inside you're going to be you're
going to be
make sure that maybe you might have to
fix the third bathroom in the in the
place
because your insides are going to just
reject it all right
yeah it's it's like you know it's like
you took your insides and you're like
what are you doing you know you shake
them
yeah this house that i'm in first of all
at one point in this it's only only been
here in this house for six weeks at one
point in the six week stay
one of all three toilets has clogged
like fully clogged
that
some was me someone said someone's my
daughter someone's homeless pimp
you know i mean but but
and also this house five betty's
three bats in ground pool beautiful
house
three thousand plus square feet the
smallest garbage can
you've ever seen in your life i gotta
throw stuff away like it's the side of
the dentist's office
i can't believe that this place hasn't
put in
a bigger garbage can it's one of those
things what i've learned about living in
a house this size
is you know you know my family wants us
to move to a bigger house and they're
sending me all these nice pictures my
question now for the real estate agent
is how big of a garbage can can i get in
there
because nobody cares that's why nobody
what i would do if i was you
i would i would i would have mentioned
something quickly to the guy
or the woman whoever's renting it to you
and say listen you know we're using this
house to capacity here
this garbage thing because sometimes
they really if they do care they really
want to know constructive criticism
what i also would have done if i was you
is i would have went right down to home
depot
or target or lowe's or a mom-and-pop
shop first if they exist
and i would have bought a big garbage
pail for yourself
i would have threw down the 50 bucks i
would have put in a 30 gallon black bag
in that thing
and i would have corrected that problem
right away i wouldn't live like that for
six weeks but
but now let me ask you a question fine
we do that we got the garbage can
do we ship it back to new york or do we
leave it here
[Music]
i think is what you do i think you say i
had an issue
i corrected it without bothering you as
a gesture i'm also leaving the pail here
and you just pay that forward let me ask
you another question
we already went ahead and we bought an
air mattress because transparent terry's
coming with this entire family so we
need a place to sleep which is on an air
mattress on the floor
do we take the air mattress with us back
to new york and ship that or do we leave
that here for the guests
who may be who chas palmitary may love
the house so much that even though we're
checking out of this airbnb
he wants to stay with the next family in
this house do we leave there do we leave
the air mattress do we send it back
okay i understand and i'm ready for the
man uh first and foremost
uh is is chaz coming and sleeping on an
air mattress
no no no no no chas chaz mr palmitary
does not sleep on air mattress
me and my family will be sleeping on the
air mattress okay
so you're shifting to the air mattress
he's taking the bed yes
well my children are sleeping on the air
mattress i'll most likely but my
children and pregnant girlfriend will be
sleeping on the air mattress i almost
gonna be sleeping on the floor
okay did you purchase the air mattress
yet
oh it's been bought okay there's a world
of difference in the air mattress space
and i'm someone who knows about this
i'm a very educated consumer as you know
yeah did you get did you get it from the
consumer value store
i did not get it from a cvs okay no i
would do a hard target search online and
read reviews and make sure i get
because there's some air mattresses that
can pass for a decent mattress
and then there's some air mattresses
that are really just pool floats
and i don't know what you plunk down for
that
but i i think the kids are sleeping on
it so maybe you're okay because
they don't know what's 160 bucks it's a
full size
we got a full size where to plug into
the wall you you got you you you plug it
in you press the on switch you turn it
to the right to inflate you turn it to
the left to deflate
okay and it's a fuller queen
i think it's do we know what it is i
think it's a i think it's a queen
you know something you know that i my
whole life me and you white wine
fanatics
right love that white wine do you know
that recently i'm not joking i started
drinking red wine
why because i got introduced to it from
bright sellers i never wanted to give it
a chance
but uh bright sellers i want to talk to
you about it
brightsellers is the wine service that
helps you find wines you love
while making wine more accessible to
everyone i'm not a wine snob
i just like that tastes good that
doesn't taste good you know what i mean
so i'm always intimidated
but if you haven't been overwhelmed in
that in the wine aisle and bought a
random wine and you end up hating it
you're not alone finding the perfect
wine match can be intimidating but it
does not have to be
that's where bright cellos comes in
whether you're new to wine world
the wine world or you've been drinking
wine for years it pairs you with unique
ones using crazy accurate algorithm
just take a 30 second quiz krista
stefano
let the magic happen they'll pair you
with six wines that fit your taste
profile
i am downing red wine like i am giving
out hosts
okay so two questions for you one now it
explains because the last time i came up
the house
you had so many wines i i saw my mother
that night she said how it sounds and
said well i mean i think he's a
sommelier because
i mean the guys got wines out the ying
yang and i couldn't figure out why but
now you said it's because bright sellers
secondly i've been looking for a wine to
enjoy while i listen to the 1975 all i
have to do now
is if i want to be transported to
england being in the front row the 1975
concert i just got to get a wine from
brightsellers.com that's all i have to
do
that's all you have to do and you could
be like a son would you call it a samoa
sommelier a samoyed that's exactly right
that's all you have to do and you can
feel better
i'm not joking dude when people come
over i love like all for why now
they're like what do you have and i open
up like i just show them the breadth of
what i have and everyone's always like
oh my god they're like so excited i feel
very adult
and look at this look at this look at
this discount that we're giving to the
fans look at because we know
how many of our fans are big winos look
at this
if you go to bright sellers that's b r i
g h t c e l l a r s
dot com backslash hay babe you get
50 off your first six bottle order
half price brightsellers.com hey babe
50 off that's only for our babes that's
50
off your first six miles from bright
sellers head to bryceos.com right now
so grab your passport a wine glass and a
1975 cd let's drink some wine
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keeping an
endless cycle of debt upstart can help
you get ahead
what is upstart upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay for debt with a personal
loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment
find out how upstart colloidal monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com hey babe do
not forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
upstart.com.com hey babe i talked right
over you
there you go well it doesn't matter now
our we're debt free
okay is there a pillow component no
okay have you tried it yet the kids have
slept on it
do you have a brand name for me
no i no i i
i it's we got it on 160 for queen
that thing is pretty heavy so to ship
that you might be looking at 30 bucks
plus
cross country i don't know if you want
to go
approaching 20 25 of the whole mattress
but then again
why not do you have one at home an air
mattress
yeah no you send that home you send it
home or if you got a suitcase
that's underpacked you throw that in
there there's no need to leave that
there no result
because that's something that's
something you could really use at home
that's something i could use at home or
you know what there's a huge homeless
uh crisis out here in l.a maybe i blow
it up i
i tie it to the roof on the way to the
airport who needs it
get it out i give somebody an air
mattress
yeah yeah i can see that i guess the
only issue they'd have is where do they
where do they plug it in to deflate it
dude did i tell you that i've been i
started watching game of thrones for the
first time
wait a minute for the first time i swear
to god i didn't watch it in real time i
never wanted to be bothered it was eight
seasons it felt like too much
i heard there was a lot of characters a
lot of names i heard you had to really
pay attention it's confusing
and i was like i was checked out and i
knew i knew that everyone loved it to
pieces
but i had a little bit of down time
recently and i was convinced
my lady convinced me to watch it because
here's the thing
we were trying to watch a show together
and every night she falls asleep and
then i don't want to go ahead because i
feel bad
so i stop it and the next night we start
again and she falls asleep
and a couple of weeks back i watch the
same episode of a program for four
nights in a row
and i said there's got to be a better
way because i can't do this i cannot do
this anymore
no she suggested watching something that
she's already seen
so that if she falls asleep it doesn't
matter
so she said game of thrones i was
hesitant to do it but i said let's do it
and i am full bore on board
with game of thrones i mean um season
four
episode six tonight is where i'm leading
on where i'm leading off tonight
season four episode six yeah you you've
watched it you've watched oh yeah
yeah yeah true that it is that it takes
a hot [ __ ] at the end or is it does it
does it hold up
out until the end i don't want to say it
takes a hot [ __ ] at the end
i will say that one of the most iconic
um
one of the biggest uh culminations
of the show is this big battle they have
uh with yeah with the um
with the with the dead people the white
walkers with the white walkers
um who who the thing is what a lot of
people aren't talking about with the
white walkers which i think now is the
perfect time to talk about is the
privilege that they had
those walkers
yeah yeah because they were in that
situation
you know and just whatever maybe that's
for another day but
i just you know whatever i just want to
say that
the beautiful blue eyes and they just
you know
just snatching up babies they come
they're not even around for a thousand
years all of a sudden they move right
into the neighborhood and they're going
to take over the neighborhood
exactly and then they're building a wall
all the people are there before the
white walkers
exactly one of the battle scenes the big
culmination is battle scene
it's like an hour battle scene the first
30 minutes of the battle
it's in pitch black you can't see a
thing that happens that's the biggest
problem i've had
with the show where i'm like this thing
that we were waiting for for years
the first 30 minutes of it they're
fighting in the dark but they didn't
think to light the set
so we could see who's we have no clue
what's happening
oh that's maddening was that like a big
was that like one of the big like
complaints online
that was a big one and then in one of
the final episodes somebody uh
accidentally left the starbucks cup but
i'm pretty sure that was just promo
they meant to do that but they that's
another big thing
yeah yeah i'm i'm in the heat of it
right now
i'm in the heat of it right now um
to put you where i am uh and if you
haven't watched
you know we're not responsible for this
right it's
no yeah if you haven't watched game of
thrones yet that's your fault
yeah and if you want to see it still and
you think that this might spoil it for
you
just jump ahead i'm sure there's a great
ad coming up soon yeah just go ahead
yeah or you could pause the show and go
see me on tour christy comedy.com i got
dates coming up we're adding a second
show at the fox theater in foxwoods
connecticut on october 23rd
and a bunch of other shows coming up
chrisdcomedy.com
23rd maybe i'll come out for that oh
sal's coming to the show now you have to
go buy the tickets that'll be fun yeah
yeah yeah i'm supposed to start touring
in october too
although we haven't announced anything
yet you're gonna are you gonna leave new
york
even with the foliage i thought that we
were gonna do that
dude i love the foliage i drive up when
it when it hits like
september i drive upstate just just to
look at foliage oh yeah crazy
no i i have like kingston
or like up by like woodstock or
something best i drive up i spend a
couple of nights and i swear to god i
stare at the foliage
me too my favorite thing to do is go
drive through the foliage go up to one
of those states pull off to the side of
the road get an apple cider and a
pumpkin donut
oh i love it the best i know
does la have foliage no no it's nothing
there's no furniture
the turning colors of foliage like the
orange the red nothing
nothing here all year round though yeah
but they have 75 degrees in sunny all
year round right yeah but after a while
you know you want you need some turmoil
you need these i'm a seasons guy
you want seasons i'm a seasoned sky but
listen neither here nor there
oh speaking of seasons season four
episode six right
i got joffrey just at his wedding that's
a done deal
and i will by the way can i just say
something i know that everybody has to
go through their transformations and
some characters come out the other end
on an
on a character arc where they maybe have
some redemption there
but and i haven't seen everyone's
complete story yet
but up season four episode six the show
is so good
and the actors in it and the writing is
so good and i swear to god i'm telling
you the truth
i had a feeling the other day where in
if i saw the actor
that played joffrey or the actress
that plays cersei or
the the actor that plays bolton if i saw
them on the street i'm a
i am an i am fully with it i know that
that's
acting i would have to restrain myself
from taking a swing at those actors
because
i have never seen people as
as despicable and morally obscene
as these people and they push it to the
point where i am
getting enraged in my home watching
this show i'm i'm getting like the vein
here
where i start i'm dropping a hard curse
i'm just like
this mother i swear i'm googling
who the actor is where he's from yeah
and what else he's done because i need
to see them in a different character
because
i swear it's that feeling like when you
want to get in your car and drive
somewhere because someone has hurt you
yes i i'm like god forbid i'm like on a
flight and cersei sits next to me
i swear to god i have all my wits about
me i
might i might take a swing at that woman
and you haven't even met
the character you're gonna hate the
most by more than joffrey more than
joffrey
oh sal jeff joffrey's gonna look like
mother teresa
character named ramsay that son of a
[ __ ] too
yes but i will tell you i will tell you
why i haven't gotten hard on him yet
because here's another thing i'm finding
when people are tortured that deserve it
i'm relishing it
normally i really don't like that kind
of thing in any respect if something is
obscenely violent someone's being
tortured
i'm like yeah let's dial it back a
little i feel bad for this person
i'm finding i i thought when joffrey
met his maker i was like it should have
been worse it should have been even
worse i wanted to see that man tortured
the way that deon greyjoy is getting to
so that's why i didn't i didn't mind too
much with ramsay just
yet because theon i was like good he
deserves it he burned those two
farm hands make him believe it was
right do you remember all this brands
yeah if you don't watch the show
we might be going off on a tangent to
the viewers so there's another show
called
viking i like vikings better because
vikings was like game of thrones
but actual in history but you know when
dragons are coming fire breathing and
killing people and then you don't even
know what happens with the dragons and
the night king it just gets
it gets insane okay but does it
unravel or do they keep the quality till
the end
some would say it starts to unravel some
would say it starts to get a little nuts
because you gotta understand by the last
season the main characters are getting
750 000
an episode so so the money starts to
become insane
um but but you know i personally
think it's it i would say
breaking bad best show of all time from
episode one through the finale
i would say game of thrones
might is probably two like how sopranos
that last episode
fell apart when it went to black and
that doesn't happen in game of thrones
okay breaking bad in my opinion but
but i would say they hold on for as long
as they could okay okay so i should just
feel confident and they're coming out
with a prequel game of thrones is not
over they're coming out with the prequel
saw that from 300 years earlier how
about this you ready for this little fun
fact i found out you know the actor
um uh the guy who gets beheaded in the
first season
what's his name ned ned stark ned stark
do you know that ned stark negotiated a
deal that
every time his name is mentioned he
would get paid
so ned stark gets so anytime they
they they they they mention edited stark
ned stark
constantly throughout that show he gets
paid every time they mention his name he
saw it being such a big show and and put
that in the contract
how do you even approach someone with
that every time they could have just
been like yeah we'll just get somebody
else
no no he's the guy
every time someone's like well ned stark
he just gets like five bucks or whatever
he gets yeah gets paid he just gets hit
yeah by the way the way they lop off
main characters in this show
really keeps you on your toes oh forget
it did you
you saw the red wedding already right um
eight episodes past the red wedding but
the red
the red wedding aired and it was the
only thing i can compare it to
and again guys if you're watching this
and you haven't seen breaking bad
or game of thrones jump to a great ad
i'm sure there's something really good
maybe it keeps
maybe it's you know maybe it's something
like uh maybe it's a policy genius
yeah exactly maybe it's babel i don't
know what it is dabble babbles great
yeah that was great
so the only thing i can compare the red
wedding to because i
i stood there for 20 minutes and said oh
my god and then rewind it and watch
again and just said oh my god repeatedly
was when in breaking bad when they
killed hank
oh yeah dude i was at my old place and i
was sitting at the foot of my bed
and i was like leaning on my things like
the tv was like three feet in front of
me
and they killed hank and then the
credits came up and i stayed like this
in this position i'm not kidding you for
30 minutes
yeah i just remember i felt i think it
rocked my world
right right yeah no i remember that i
did you catch comey camino el camino
the movie the breaking bad movie about
jet about uh jessie's life after the end
no we don't even know no i didn't even
know that they made a movie about
jesse's life
what wait this is your favorite show you
gotta watch this
tonight el camino a breaking bad movie
it's breaking bad movie that starts the
second the series ends
and it's a movie yes and it's great
you saw it yes do you imagine i said no
right now
[Laughter]
oh ben you got to watch it it's full-on
breaking bad well that's what i'm going
to watch tonight did you better call
solid or did you stop there
i've never seen you better call saul
okay so
i i watched the first few episodes it
didn't get its teeth into me
and i let it go by the wayside but my
cue
told me that it's as good if not better
than breaking bad which i think
sounds crazy to me and if that's true
then we all should be watching
well accused idiots yeah
i mean he wouldn't say so it must be
that good but
but why don't we hear unless it's just
me but why don't we hear the hubbub
about saul like we did with breaking bad
yeah breaking bad it's just one of those
things where
it was it's like it was like a
life-changing
tv show you know better call saul i
understand people say it's good but
you know it's it's not it's not gonna be
you know it's not gonna be better call
it's not it's not it's not breaking bad
i
you know i i remember what breaking bad
was so good to me
i i've actually never watched it again i
felt like it would be disrespectful to
go back into it again i've only watched
it once
and i made my piece i have news for you
i'm starting to think that i want to
give a re-watch to all the best shows
i've ever seen
and now you've gone insane no really do
you think that do you think that you
remember every little nook and cranny
of breaking bad or do you think that
it'd be
just as an enjoyable second watch
because i'm contemplating doing
a breaking bad again a sopranos again
and i'm not sure at first i said loss
but lost
really lost was the best show ever for
like four or five seasons and then
the last three or four seasons were like
what are you doing to
us when saying not fair yeah yeah let me
ask you this
can you say the words nook and cranny
without thinking of thomas's english
muffins
no not at all i just thought of it when
i said that and
i know what a nook is i'm not exactly
sure what a cranny is
no but also here's how about this i was
in trader joe's the other day
and i bought their version of an english
muffin which is a different version i
think they call it a new england version
of something
and it's different but it's it's as good
wow it's very thick and dense with a
crunchy outside but it's chewy inside it
doesn't have that many nooks and
crannies though
like there's actually no nook and
crannies and i really was
chastising it out of the package but
then i i just toasted one up nice i
bought it up
i took a bite and right away i was a
believer but
thomas's english muffin for me outside
of like a
i mean a brick oven fresh baked bread
with the
flour still on it like that kind of
bread i think of thomas's english moment
i don't know what they did or they sold
their souls to the devil
but i think a thomas is english muffin
like i say this you can go to like a
michelin star restaurant and give me
your best dish then
give me a buttered thomas's english
muffin yeah just like it's
close it's going to be it's very close
there's a restaurant in la i went with
the family a couple of
weeks ago it's called the nook it's
called the nook i think it's in like
studio city
it's called the nook and i asked the
waiter i said do you guys have another
restaurant called the cranny
and he looked at me and said no our
other restaurants called miguels
he knew he was saying right i think but
he just said no
actually our other restaurants called
miguel's would you like an iced tea i i
think i love that guy because i think
that he has that in the chamber
for the one million times he's heard the
cranny reference you know what i mean
what is it can can compen yeah pimp's
gonna find out what a cranny is right
now i've done this i feel
like we've done it let me tell you
something if a cranny is another
way to say nook you ready for what a
cranny is sal
yeah a small narrow space or opening
uh now look here's a nook
a nook is a small recessed section of a
larger room
though it's redundant it's redundant so
maybe
but they're marketing geniuses because
honestly if it was just like
thomas's english muffin you'll love the
nooks yeah
i don't know what resonated the same
nooks and crannies is where it is
i feel i i've never even heard nook
without the word cranny
but i will tell you this i want to start
saying cranny
i just want to stop referring to stuff
as a cranny like on your couch right
there see the little split
in the couch yeah yellow cranny right
there the little
that little leather cranny yeah yeah
right there it's fun
yeah it's fun it's fun yeah i always say
like when you know i'm teaching my
daughter i use the toilet i want to say
baby you got to make sure you get all
the poop out of your cranny
yeah you don't want to get poo-poo stuck
in the cranny
no i love that yeah but
um what um all right so
where are you yeah what'd you say where
were we at where were we at
well no i was going to um i was gonna uh
uh
say that i got this crazy
like actually kind of and i know we've
been talking about it a lot
um and i know the episodes was going on
a little bit this freaking thing dude
the craziest thing happened to me um
with the magician david blaine and
that's hey babe
i love a cliffhanger yes
here's the only thing i don't know the
story and that's a genuine clip
that's even that even messes me up there
it is thanks guys for listening if you
want of course hey babe every thursday
11 a.m eastern time go check out taste
buds
uh every monday 11 a.m eastern time i
have a podcast chrissy chaos
every tuesday 11 a.m eastern time uh you
can go uh
have fun with that and christy
comedy.com for all my stand up dates
we've added a show at the fox theater
october 23rd all most of the other shows
are sold out philadelphia
we just opened up tickets august 18 to
the 21st i'm doing eight shows down
there
so we just added some tickets so get
them quick and uh and yeah
eatontown new jersey we got shows we're
going to put atlantic city on sale so go
go get your tickets for me i i i really
appreciate it and seriously i'm excited
i'm excited to see you
i'm excited to see you so i'm excited we
haven't been coming in a while
i want to see your new stuff i've been
seeing clips i'm excited to get back on
stage too i'm excited
i'll i'll say my dates when i have but
go see chris i'm so freaking psyched
to see your new stuff thank you baby and
guess what i'm excited about to finally
get home and enjoy with you
our new saratoga peanut butter if you go
to yo peanut.com
we gotta take we got hey bay peanut
butter we got a taste buds peanut butter
and they flew off the shelves
i can't wait i'm already through my
first jar of each
there you go yeah and it's it's so
it's so good it's so good you're gonna
love have you
tasted it yet no i haven't tasted
anything yet i've been stuck in this
coffee shaking city
i ordered like a case of it i have so
much of it it's so good all right let's
do it
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey